no matter you are crazy
okay yeah soon over 30 years of working
as a chef has all been leading to this
moment
catching a Peruvian cactus worm with
Alice ooh you gotta get up here first
[Laughter]
see this is super dangerous
what you can't taste see boy you see the
point is
[Laughter]
Ricola comida Rica seriously Umberto
gonna be delicious
I'm proud of you ma go on this pass your
sink our damn jajaja este goes on
Asilomar why Tampa the like giant
caterpillars how did he first learn
about these nosotros estamos Camille is
the antis neutral ancestral me papa
Millie Baba and on this is Sakura
mostafa axis and how we first started
dangling off the side of a cliff with
your dad looking for what you see Stan
you associate annual six or seven
amazing I'm just gonna getting with a
little bit dry yeah just so it doesn't
crackle okay thank you
the Odyssey this way Chilean vegetarian
stop it yo are most common yeah you know
passante protein ax cuando chrome is not
Iranian retold yeah yeah nice to see go
measure the ratio so
[Laughter]
it's like a it's like a crispy like a
crispy cockroach the taste was crispy to
begin with fine
however the inside no no bueno but this
is how they survived so remotely protein
growing literally in a cactus he said an
amazing secret and a big owner wanna see
more from my uncharted adventures please
click here to watch more clips